ah
Walter
what up wastelanders I'm Kate and this
is game spots fallout mod of the week
finally we have been told that bethesda
of releasing mod tools' in April so as
much as we're loving of Rhys kins and
the endless weapon mods it will be
really nice to see some more creative
game-changing tinkering inside the game
but this week we're taking a look at ex
gruffy jerry's immersive vendor's mod
which spruces up your settlements vendor
shack so they don't look so sad and
lonely with this mod each stall will
have relevant items stacked up around
the place making them feel a little more
homely and a little less like everyone
in the Fallout universe has Mary Poppins
style pockets the attention to detail is
fantastic and really true to the spirit
an aesthetic of the game the armor stall
looks like a tiny army surplus store the
weapons store stacks its guns in racks
and its ammo on little shelves and the
clothing store has sunglasses lined up
in front like you'd see in a street
market
there's even an option to put giant
props on top of the stalls a big hat a
huge nuka-cola quantum so you can see at
a glance what each one sells of course
this signs pretty much do all the hard
work for you there but maybe you'd like
a bit of novelty why not the Creator has
future plans for the mod like having the
stands empty at night and being able to
select an indoor variant which
presumably means the sign on top won't
be quite as tall maybe by the time April
comes around this mod will be even more
immersive if you want to make your
settlements look a little more lived-in
then you can find the link for this mod
in the description and if you've already
tried it out we'd love to hear from you
so tell us what you thought in the
comments and let us know if there are
any more mods you think we should check
out make sure to come back next week for
another episode and another mod until
then I'm Kate and stay safe out there
wasteland err